at moments like this it can be
important to talk outside church on the
windsor estate
the duke of edinburgh's daughter-in-law
sophie shared details of his final
moments
it was so gentle
[Music]
the council of wessex prince edward and
daughter lady louise
had joined the duke of york for the
sunday morning service
prince andrew describing how the queen
is coping
i feel very sorry and supportive of my
mother who's
feeling it i think probably more than
everybody else
she described uh his passing as a
miracle
and um and she's um
contemplating i think is the way that i
would put it there she described it as
as having left a huge void
it's the first time that he's spoken
since he's stepped away from royal
duties
so telling to hear him talk about prince
philip's unwavering support
i loved him as a father he was so
um calm
if you had a problem he would think
about it
and that's the that's the great thing
that i always think about is that he was
always somebody you could go to and he
would always listen
so it's a great loss
i think the way i would put it is that
we've lost almost the grandfather of the
nation
he used to give you a lot of hard time
there's a horse that shouldn't be there
talking to staff who work on the estate
the family swaps stories of what a
character he'd been
he went carriage driving around here on
a regular basis and and
but he'd go to places that you know were
quite you know all over the place and uh
so we're just talking about them killed
out of a few ditches here i seem to
remember as well oh well
the early days yes you saw a few
problems
more recently too the tributes have been
just
fantastic and that's really really
important and we really do appreciate it
last year the queen and prince philip
posed outside of the same
church for princess bitches's wedding
now ahead of his funeral
windsor continues to be the focus for
tributes
it is incredibly rare to hear members of
the royal family speaking this
personally
and i think one of the reasons they are
is because they can't come out and see
for themselves the flowers that people
are bringing
but they do want to acknowledge just how
much it means to them
and also how they've been lifted by
hearing those memories of prince philip
some that they've never even heard
before
it's understood the queen attended mass
privately
inside the castle in difficult times the
nation
often turns to her for support now
her majesty and her family are finding
comfort
from the public as they face this moment
of enormous change rhiannon mills
sky news at windsor castle